you
[Music]
okay so thank you for four great days so
I'm before before Sandy dragged me up
off the stage I really want to thank him
as well so of course him and his team
I know Mariah has kept on keeping me on
schedule but really sandy has also put a
huge amount of time and effort into this
so I think he really deserves a round of
applause so thank you sandy and and I
also want to extend special thanks to
kind of my partner in crime here or the
Dan Fay who who was the co PC chair and
we had many short-term kind of
discussions and phone calls and
everything so really thanks you really
made it happen and it was a it was a
great event so thanks dad yeah but of
course also I would like to love to
thank all of you for coming here again
busy schedules but these last two days
were really amazing the amount of energy
was just outstanding and so so I'm I
think you should give yourself a round
of applause as well so thank you very
much okay so I I showed this slide
yesterday in in order to introduce mark
russinovich and and Azure
and I'm actually going to use or I'm
gonna tee off this slide use the slide
to tee off my kind of final closing
thoughts and so the the way kind of we
at Microsoft mostly think about this
slide and you've heard this slogan many
times is intelligent edge intelligent
cloud and so we essentially say well
there's this public cloud everything
that has that we don't fully understand
and has some shape right in this cloud
form maybe even private cloud that's our
intelligent cloud abundant computing and
so ever we put it there and then we have
all these devices and our mobile phones
our our toy cars that that are connected
to the Internet and that's what we call
the intelligent edge all right and we
we've kind of really also reason about
it and why we do this right we have the
intelligent edge is where we collect the
data that's where we make decisions
because the decisions have to be
implemented fast and also this is kind
of the environment we trust a little bit
more our phone is with us we trust it a
little bit more of course it can be
hacked but the but it's kind of close to
us whereas the cloud is somehow remote
and the cloud is where we have abundant
computing we typically don't trust
what's going on it has higher latency
but that's where we do data analytics
that's where we do training so that's
how we mostly think about this this
world with all the I almost press the
red button here but I didn't say
everything to go back one side so this
is how we mostly think about the world
and its kind of nicely petitioned and so
on so my final thought is that actually
because of what Albert was talking about
all this cable and hyper connectivity I
think we we now have something else
essentially this is all moving together
and it's it's kind of transforming to
one big supercomputer that we sometimes
and you might have heard that term as
well call the global AI supercomputer
and this is like think of everything all
the computing devices somehow they're
all connected through the internet
through the same logical fabric of
course there is their virtual Nets as
Albert mentioned yesterday but somehow
they're all connected them and this is
one big machine and I think this is this
is the the picture or the metaphor that
I would like to use kind of for these
brief closing remarks before
he catches me off the after stage
because he wants to go home right I
assume yeah we all want to go home so
there are essentially two perspectives
on this supercomputer there's the curve
that we probably are familiar with is
the internal perspective where we
essentially look at the components at
each or a set of components of this
supercomputer let's say a drone that
communicates with a mobile phone for
example but there's also the external
perspective where we really look at this
as one machine just think of it this is
one machine just as today your your
phone is not just or your even your car
is not just one CPU processor your car
probably has 100 CPUs inside and your
your your your PC has a greater GPU
inside has several cause inside it has
in future it might have some
accelerators inside yeah so just think
of this now as this one big machine yeah
and the the important thing and I'll
come to that I'll first go to the
internal perspectives that most of the
people in the world are not systems
researchers like us yeah so systems
researchers yeah look at the components
and somehow how they interact but most
of the people on this planet look at the
experience that they have with computing
as as a kind of one experience as one
machine and in the old days if this was
a PC and then it was a phone but now it
is really all of these devices that
create these experiences so I want to go
a little bit through these two
perspectives and start with the internal
perspective because most of the talks
that we had here and most of the
discussion that we had here was really
on the internal perspective and and that
is great great to see and it's all great
work this is what our everyday job and
it's a lot of fun and we should
definitely and must
to continue that right so all the work
we have done in in improving components
or connections or pieces of this big
supercomputer those are still important
and highly relevant and we still want to
want to keep that work alive and there
are a lot of new ideas and and that is
kind of why this I felt that this this
the summit was so exciting because even
though that we've been doing this for I
don't know 50 years 60 years or since
for Noah and also I obviously I haven't
been doing it for sixty years and most
of you not there are continuously new
ideas exciting ideas to do this and
we've heard many of them yeah there was
a there was a whole track on AI four
systems there was work on how to predict
workloads how to predict what is the
best decision and this is really
exciting and that wasn't that didn't
definitely not exist five or even three
years ago this kind of thinking and work
there is this whole line of work of
synthesizing code or instance optimize
system yesterday there was this session
R which was talking about learned
indexes where you where you kind of use
machine learning to create data
structures and algorithms there was talk
about software 2.0 a very new way to
create software which actually I'll come
to might actually become relevant there
are systems for AI we now have I'm a
database person so we optimize database
systems because we know the operations
that we need to do with AI you also kind
of know the operations we need to do we
had a lot of this and as several talks
during those faculty summit focusing on
that this is a whole new great kind of
mining pool for ideas and great work to
be custom hardware security we talked a
lot about about enclaves about Intel SGX
or hyper FPGAs hardware software code
design Crossley optimizations
work is some of these ideas are very new
some of these ideas are old and kind of
done in a new context and all that is
very exciting and we should continue to
do that but what I would like to focus
on is the external perspective what
really society expects from us or the
what I mean what we usually say as a
what my grandmother expects from me to
to deliver and so the first we are
creating or I mean we are big part of
creating this big machine and the first
question that kind of society asks us
what is the value of this machine and I
think we should also step back and kind
of think about that as well and those
are these questions so and those are
technical questions as well how do I
program this machine yeah how do I use
this machine right plainly with my
telephone with my smartphone it's very
clear with my PC it's a screen at the
keyboard it has speakers the interaction
modalities are very clear here there are
so many interaction modalities and they
keep on growing the programming and the
interaction becomes very very
interesting because of course we want to
program experiences for the user but
what is the set of the devices that the
user has available for the experience
that I want to program I know very
little about the the kind of the context
and even the computational context and
of my application for my user and that
is obviously going to make my
programming app my programming do my
tasks of programming the application
more difficult every user probably there
are no two users in this room that have
exactly the same set of devices in their
normal everyday life and then of course
the the big questions are what what can
I do with this machine that I couldn't
do before right
this is not only for us and I'll get to
that to answer that question because
most of the really interesting things
that we are doing are kind of solving
the world's biggest problems climate
change and so on it's not that we can do
this alone
even as computer science community but
of course we have to reach out to other
scientific disciplines and and also to
the rest of society and then of course
the the most exciting questions for us
and I'm not saying that these are easy
to answer questions is what can't I do
and what I would like to do so that's
the that's the first thing I think as a
that we have to kind of deliver the
second thing of course there's the
that's the plus side and we all know
that society expects from us also to
very carefully think about the minus
side and so we really have to think
about the risk and as security was a
huge topic here over the over these last
two days so what can go wrong how do i
hack this machine and of course this
machine has every year and there are
nine billion new microcontrollers
produced so there every year we are
producing at least nine billion attack
points and so we can leak information
that we don't want to leak as somebody
can change our information I'm not
particularly happy if somebody like I
want to I want to go to the Olympic
Peninsula on the on the weekend I've
booked the ferry boat and if somebody
changes the ticket of my ferry boat
without me noticing I'm not going to be
very happy and a lot of this if you if
you think about it is going to be the
queen of the big questions is about how
to compose security we haven't talked
much about that here but it is something
that we at Microsoft really struggle
with greatly because we have many secure
we have many great ideas too many great
protocols and many great ideas to
solve a specific security problem in a
particular context but now if you put a
puzzle all of these contexts together
and look at different paths through it
you knew that's where the big problems
come in security and then of course
there's a whole regulation aspect how do
we as Microsoft is a big problem for us
prove that we are gdpr compliant for
example we we want to be gdpr compliant
this is it's really something we're
doing huge efforts to do that but of
course we want to prove and we're proud
of all the efforts that we are doing we
want to prove that and on the other side
of course we want to understand
regulators and how they how they how
they when they specify the regulations
like gdpr and other regulations and then
of course there's the the normal systems
aspect of this and so there's a plus
side on my side and of course we need to
optimize this machine and and of course
many of us work on this and again at
different aspects and that's where
things again if you optimize this
machine at some point that might not
matter in the bigger context but we
really kind of now computing is the
biggest energy consumer on the planet
and you know all about these stories
about that Bitcoin and aetherium the the
proof of work I mean this is this is a
major sustainability and climate change
fact you know it's it's because starting
to be a factor because because of the
economics of consuming energy in in the
in this thing so we have a huge
responsibility here to optimize for the
sustainability of the of the planet and
so there are all these other other
questions because this is a machine that
is not owned by anybody yes it's owned
by all of us and some pieces might be
owned by different people Microsoft
might have a fairly big
share like because it has many servers
but overall this is still tiny compared
to the magnitude of this big machine so
all of these questions are pretty big
and it's not really kind of yeah you
would say okay yeah that's a good
research topic but then if you think
about it five minutes you'll say well
really what can I do right and so what
I'm gonna do is I'm just going to give
you some examples how we at Microsoft
Research have been going about this kind
of addressing some of these questions in
a way so we have don't have access to
this machine it's kind of woven into our
society and out into our planet and into
our everyday lives and we cannot really
access it it's a kind of as it's
invisible and it's not a test bed that
we cannot put it into a lab and
replicate it in the lab even with all
the with all the cloud computing and
simulation that we have even that we
cannot simulate it and we cannot
replicate it in a lab so the way to
really go about it is to take a slice of
this machine and that's a very different
thinking then that we have typically in
in systems research where in systems
research you usually take a vertical
slice you look at the stack and then you
took and you take a piece a vertical
slice of the stack yeah but what I'm
going to talk about or what I'm gonna
give examples are slices that I kind of
go not necessary vertically and
horizontally they go in zigzag through
what this this machine is about and I'm
gonna start with one example which might
be surprising here but I'll do it which
is kind of how we thought about
education and one of the examples where
Microsoft engaged and all of these
examples are also examples that are not
MSR internal or even Microsoft internal
they are all example
we reached out with somebody else in in
the world mostly in academia and so the
first one was about education and and
the reason why I'm saying this this is a
interesting piece of schooling hardware
this micro bit I don't know who has
heard of it it's a very simple processor
with some interactions it has some
lights and it has a little bit of
sensing and and this is a piece of
hardware that BBC in in in in the UK has
advertised and has shipped to schools
and is available you can buy it that you
can get it kit but it also comes and
this is the right side of that picture
with a programming model so this is its
education how to bring people how to how
to convince people to or and children in
the in this case really children how to
make them program of course in a in a
playful manner right this is not real
applications and this is really not
going to gonna solve climate change this
this application but they learn
programming through a web interface
through a graphical thing and I'm
showing a little bit some piece of code
and then they can run it and they can
experience a device yeah and they can
experience into and the the concept is
called physical programming and it's one
way kind of how hardware with software
engineering somehow comes together
hardware design with software
engineering to create something in the
educational space I'm gonna give you
another example that we had this morning
actually heard it twice this morning
because of technical issues and it's
exactly that slide of course I cry I
stole that slide I'm allowed to do that
as a lab director is the farm beats
project and again my my point here is it
is motivated by a real-world problem and
then it looks and it changed through the
components that are needed in this
global AI supercomputer and there's a
lot of AI here but there's a lot of
systems work in here you see the class
essentially happens is a drone flies
over a field take pictures takes
pictures these pictures are kind of a
little bit pre-filtered but they are
kind of going through through this TV
white spaces network to some edge device
or a gateway where they are kind of
further processed there's some AI done
they then go to the cloud where there's
a little bit more comprehensive area
done in order to understand what is
going on in this field what is the
humidity what is the water kind of
saturation of the of the soil in that
field and we we have this demo of of the
how the how the FPGA can actually do do
this real-time kind of AI on image
processing and then of course it goes
back to the gateway in order to make
local decisions at the at the at the
gateway on the farm on how to kind of do
watering and pesticides and chemicals on
that field again it is something that is
motivated by a real-world need somehow
goes in a very complex way through this
AI supercomputer and by studying these
we learn a huge amount about how to
build systems how to optimize them and
how to make the the what I said
yesterday this 1% improvement how make
that how to make that really really
matter and valuable I'm going to give
two more examples
the next example this is again as a
chart that I didn't do it's a typical
one of these industry block charts but
you really don't have to understand it
I'm just going to tell you the story
what this is about is a water project in
California and again it's a
collaboration farm beads is a
collaboration with many agricultural
companies but also with several
universities just yesterday evening I
was talking to Hakim at Cornell who
who's who's actually also Cornell is
also collaborating as part of farm bees
this is a water project in California a
collaboration with University of
California and Davis hoo-hoo-hoo kind of
are the masterminds of of water planning
and the problem there is really that you
would think that water is well this is a
simple problem you collect all the data
and that's it but they're like four
hundred different data sources that are
needed to reason about water supply and
consumption in California one of the big
problems is leakage is where you waste
water because some pipe is broken but
just finding that out sounds like
technically from our perspective easy
but really to get there you have to
integrate data from multiple sources and
as it is some of these sources don't
like to share their data because they
are afraid that they're doing something
wrong that is not compliant or because
they have a competitive advantage as a
water supplier in their particular
region and so what this really just
shows is the is the flow of the data how
you kind of integrate it in a in a kind
of trusted way so that not every party
how do you then analyze it build
different applications and then how you
make at the very right side some of
those some of those results again openly
available to make decisions governmental
decisions in California about water the
last example I want to show is is one
that I'm involved in myself and I'm
saying it because we've been talking
about blockchain I think everybody knows
this cartoon from I think it's from the
early 90s it's in New York on the
internet nobody knows that you're a dog
right and it's somehow husband it has
been in my mind I love this cartoon for
yeah because I think I'm a dog and I'm
I was always very happy that the
Internet didn't know who I really was
but there are cases where you
essentially do want to do something on
the internet or you do want to do
something digitally and you want the
other side to know really this is me
right I'm actually going through a very
weird
so IRS I did my tax return everything is
fine but IRS believes that I'm that I'm
spanning a spamming my that I stole my
own identity so they didn't want to pay
me back my return and now they are kind
of trying to somehow find a way that I
can convince them that I meet yeah so
this is actually a an interesting
problem for the IRS but it's also and
more interesting maybe and more
interesting problem in a much more
mundane thing so let's say I'm kind of
the person think of the top I'm the the
second to the left I'm a person I have a
phone and I want to kind of maybe not
even on the internet I want to buy a
glass of champagne and I want to pay for
it digitally and I want to somehow let's
assume I want to I want to I forgot my
driver's license my paper I want to
somehow prove digitally that I am older
than 21 yeah yeah okay you wouldn't you
wouldn't question that I'm older than 21
but let's just assume that that is a
very kind bartender that wants to kind
of be nice to me and ask me and cause me
so that is the case so essentially today
you you really have to have the driver's
license there's no way for me to prove
digitally that I'm 21
right and that I can drink alcohol and
because online casinos might have this
problem but they probably don't care
that much about this problem so there's
a government that issues kind of IDs
there is a bank that issues IDs credit
cards are in some sense IDs that are
issued by banks and and
and but we want to do this all digital
in China it's all digital in the way
that Alibaba or 10 cent they issue the
IDS that you do for banking and nobody
else but we really don't want to do that
in our culture we don't want to trust
just one provider like Alibaba to issue
IDs for payments so the idea here and
again this is a it's a it's a problem
motivated and it's open this is this
whole work is kind of standard by w3c
and but it has many computational and
systems aspects that I want to get to
that so what is happening here
essentially we are creating these
digital IDs everybody can create digital
IDs at any time and they are stored in
blockchains
and if there's a government ID well it
will be digitally signed by the
government and the government can issue
it can give it to me and I can choose to
participate in this very open system and
a blockchain system think of like
Bitcoin and just put it there yeah and
what I would put there is not my my
driver's license with all the
information what I would really put
there is just a hash plus I would put
there something and a pointer kind of
that points to that signed document yeah
and so this is this is think of this all
these IDs or hashes of these IDs in the
blockchain they will point to some other
distributed database that will have
again hashes of the dot of where you can
look up those documents so that I can
prove digitally with my driver's license
but still no information is revealed and
to make that all work on top of that we
have what we call these site Reno's
which take kind of all the information
our there's an update right I got to my
I got a new credit card after the old
one expired I got a new drivers license
all right there's some amendment to to
my I have a telephone contract and I
amended it to to have
to have a bigger data plan all of these
requests come in they are batched put
together and then kind of hashed and put
into the into the blockchain in a very
efficient way plus there are these sigh
tree notes that if the bartender really
wants to verify my my my my driver's
license and look at my age I would say
well I will present my my hash digital
ID the bartender will go to this system
and it can go to any of these side tree
notes the ultimate source of truth is
the blockchain will we'll get in a
pointer to two to the real driver's
license that I will then present through
my phone and then the the bartender can
validate that again the pattern is very
open system many many many parties
collaborating here without any trust
root of trust you the blockchain is a
collaborative way to create trust if you
don't try the the caches and somehow
they can be operated by anybody you
could operate one of those caches on
your phone if you want to you don't have
to trust anybody there or you kind of
have an economy of trust and then you
implement a scenario a real-world
scenario use a human centered scenario
and this is another kind of weird slice
through this a ice global AI
supercomputer that we are kind of all
collectively building so with that I
want to kind of close the at least my
pod until sandy comes back on stage in
the same way that I opened when I when I
said I Dream have come true right I said
well what it is that really we can now
change the world we everything we do
really matters that's how I started it
but now when I say I'm kind of I'm
trying to give a different perspective
on exactly that same quote that I made
yesterday morning
it is we've created or there is now a
toy for us that is super super fun for
us to play with and what kind of this
faculty summit is about is come on let
us play together with this toy alright
and and there are many ways you can
engage and play with us with this the
best way of course for you is I mean you
have an idea come to us and say yeah I
want to do this right like I want to do
water in California I want to fix the
water problem in California in Southern
California right
another way is you send your students to
us as part of the internship I hope
you're doing that anyway but that's a
that's a very lightweight engagement but
of course we also have other programs
sandy was mentioning some of them we
have visiting researcher programs you
can be a consulting researcher we have
all of these programs but the real
message is we have this wonderful toy
let us play with it thank you very much
[Applause]
you